no no hubo ninguna garantía
esta es una eslabón más en la cadena de
atrocidades que se han cometido en lo
que se han llamado juicio prácticamente
es el preso politikoen número 48 que el
combo en una estrategia única han sido
condenados durante desde el primero de
febrero a
esta parte no hubo ninguna diferencia no
hubo ningún aporte de la prueba
cual lorenzo es completamente inocente
es lo más infundado y absurdo esa
tipificación de delitos del lavado del
lavado de dinero y eso no retrasa más
que la decisión del régimen de daniel
ortega de impulsar y de aplicar sin
ninguna distinción su estrategia de
terror su estrategia de persecución de
odio encarnizado en contra de toda
aquella persona que nicaragua piense que
piense democráticamente
y siente su decisión de terminar con el
régimen de control que nos desgobierna
qué puede pasar con esta sentencia
analizando el contexto que vive
nicaragua actualmente hay alguna forma
de apelar la
desidia mente dentro de las formalidades
legales que aparentemente se quieren
impulsar está previsto que esta
sentencia es completamente una ciudad se
apelaba en un término de 12 días después
que fue éste notificada el día de ayer
después de sentencia de apelación si el
resultado es adverso como efectivamente
va a hacer para él para cuando lorenzo
hay todavía la posibilidad de recurrir
al recurso extraordinario de casación
pero definitivamente ni nosotros lo que
estuviéramos derecho ni lo que estamos
abogados y los defensores de derechos
humanos vemos en una de esas tramitación
de estos juicios en ninguna de esas
instancias ninguna de esas etapas
ninguna posibilidad de reversión de la
barbarie jurídica del atropello a la
inteligencia y a lo que el respeto que
debe tener una instancia misma ahora la
noticia prácticamente se está asistiendo
a la persecución indiscriminada de
personas inocentes pero también a la
destrucción definitiva del poder
judicial que su independencia es la que
garantiza precisamente la vigencia de
los derechos humanos en país
definitivamente hacemos un llamado a la
comunidad internacional de que no nos
cansemos a veces uno se siente como
arando en el desierto como tirando y
llamados y esfuerzos para
venga sabemos que tenemos un gran camino
por recorrer ya que están impulsando una
serie de mecanismos y una serie de
iniciativas a nivel internacional y les
pedimos a todos los que están apoyando a
los valores o los que están apoyando a
todos los presos injustamente de
nicaragua a que sigamos impulsando